Hallo zusammen, ich bin Sam von der Flugstelle Free Wings und wir schauen heute zusammen das Thema Materialkunde an.
Es ist ein Thema, das ihr vielleicht schon ein bisschen angeschaut habt im Theoriebuch oder auch schon Theoriefragen angeschaut habt und es sind relativ viele Fachbegriffe, Fremdwörter im Spiel.
Das sind Sachen, die man einerseits ein bisschen auswendig lernen muss, aber wir versuchen heute all dem Ganze ein bisschen ins Gesicht zu geben, damit ihr hier einen Bezug habt und es so einfacher zu lernen wird.
Was wir heute anschauen, ist, dass wir mal schauen, was es überhaupt für Fluggeräte gibt, dass ihr hier einen Hintergrund erfahrt, wo es verschiedene Flug-Gleitschirme gibt, wo man auch verschiedene Sachen damit machen kann, das von hier beim Akrobatik-Gleitschirm bis zum Schulschirm.
Wieso es überhaupt ein Gleitschirm aufgebaut ist, vom Material her schauen wir an, wir schauen die Kurzung an, wir schauen die Notschirme an und wir schauen die Materialien dafür spezifisch.
Wir schauen ganz speziell auch die Leitschirmleine, weil dort noch richtig wichtig ist, dass man ein bisschen wissen kann, wie sich das Ganze verhalten tut.
Wenn wir die Leitschirmkategorien anschauen, haben wir einerseits den Schulschirm, das ist jetzt dieses Bild ganz im linken Ecken oben, der weiß-rote, da sehen wir schon, das ist ein einfacher Schirm gebaut, der ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig fest gestreckt, sondern eigentlich wirkt relativ kompakt.
Und der grosse Unterschied zu einem Schulschirm und einem Wettkampfschirm,
wie man den mitten schlägt, ist, dass der Schirm nicht so sehr fest gestreckt ist, sondern er wirkt relativ kompakt.
Was wir hier in der Mitte vom Fatterli sehen, ist schlussendlich, dass der Schirm so bobbt, dass er sicher ist.
Dort ist die Sicherheit absolut das Wichtigste. Nicht so wichtig ist die Leistung.
Unterkategorisiert wie der Wettkampfschirm ist es sehr gerade ein umgekehrtes.
Dort ist die Leistung wichtig und die Sicherheit ein bisschen weiter heruntergestaucht.
Denn dort verlangt man vom Piloten bereits, dass er sehr viel kann und damit kann umgehen.
Dann gibt es noch viele Unterkategorien.
Wir haben zum Beispiel in der rechten Ecke hier ein ganz spezielles Modell,
Untersegel hat, nur ein Obersegel.
Da wird natürlich experimentiert und selbst
dieser Flugteil ist speziell gemacht
für Hike & Fly, dass man ein sehr
kleines Päckchen hat mit ganz wenig Volumen
und vor allem wenig Gewicht.
Und dann geht das Gegenteil,
die sehr robust gebaut sind,
auch das Gewicht spielt keine Rolle.
Das ist der Akrobatikschirm, den man hier
in weiß-blau sieht, der gemacht ist,
damit man Manöver mit dem
Schirm fliegen kann, die
extremste Gehkräfte, extremste Belastungen
auf dem Schirm wirken, aber
das Material hält, weil
es eben so verbaut ist, richtig stark
gebaut ist. Und
gibt es noch Kategorien von
Speedgliedern, wo man mit der Ski
und ganz kleinen Schirmchen rumfliegt.
Auch das ist schlussendlich
eine Form von Gleitschirmfliegen.
Allerdings eine andere Kategorie,
worauf wir jetzt nicht genau eingehen.
Das ganze Gleitschirmfliegen
ist auch eingestuft
in verschiedene
Kommunikationen. Wir haben A, B,
C und D. Und beim
A-Schirm sprechen wir vom Schuhschirm.
Das heisst, wie es hier steht, dass
die Passivsicherheit sehr hoch ist.
Schlussendlich ist eigentlich die Idee, dass wenn
irgendeine Störung am Schuhschirm passiert
und der Pilot einfach los lässt,
dass der Schirm wieder für einen selbstständigen
Geradeausflug zurückkehrt.
Das wäre eigentlich der Wunsch, den jeder Schuhschirm
erfüllen müsste.
Jeder Konstrukteur, der einen Schirm
macht, versucht möglichst fest
an das hinzukommen. Und da sind wir
heute in einem Bereich, wo wir heute sagen können,
wir fliegen die Fange sehr, sehr sicher
und haben eben trotzdem auch schon
eine relativ gute Leistung.
Leistung, als kleine Gedankenstütze,
reden wir immer davon, von
Gleitleistung. Das heisst, wenn wir
zum Beispiel von 1000 Metern
bei ruhiger Luft starten und einfach ins Tal
rausfliegen, kommen wir vielleicht
mit einem Schuhschirm 8 Kilometer
weit. Mit einem Wettkampfschirm sind wir
mittlerweile etwa bei 12 Kilometern.
Also da ist schon eine Differenz, aber 8 Kilometer
ist auch schon sehr, sehr gut, wenn wir
vergleichen, dass noch vor wenigen Jahren
wir bei 6, 7,5 Kilometern waren und jetzt
sind wir eher bei 8 Kilometern.
Dann geht es weiter mit einem B,
welches der Intermade-Schirm ist,
bei dem die meisten Piloten wahrscheinlich fliegen.
Weil das so ein bisschen das ist,
wo nach dem Schulschirm, wenn man schon ein paar Flüge
gemacht hat, ich rede hier eher von ein paar Hundert
Flüge, die man hoffentlich im Schulschirm gemacht hat,
zum B-Schirm geht, welches auch noch eine
recht gute passive Sicherheit hat,
aber doch auch schon ein bisschen Leistung
und der Pilot muss auch schon ein bisschen wissen,
was er macht, also respektive auch schnell reagieren
auf eine Störung.
Und das umso mehr beim D-Schirm,
wenn wir richtig weg am Schirm gehen,
ist das definitiv der Fall.
Da verlangt es vom Pilot, dass er sofort reagiert,
dass er nicht mehr überlegen muss, was er macht,
wenn die in diese Situation eintrifft,
sondern dann muss er auch gleich intuitiv reagieren,
ohne noch vorher gross überlegen zu müssen,
was dann eigentlich los ist mit dem Schirm.
Wie kommt ein Schirm überhaupt
zu so einem A, B, C oder D?
Das nennt man das Gütersiegel.
Und das Gütersiegel ist mittlerweile
eigentlich die N-Norm,
die man antrifft.
Es ist weltweit gültig, ausser in Deutschland.
In Deutschland ist man nach wie vor auf LTF,
das ist das ehemalige DAV-Gütersiegel.
Das ist ein absolutes Detail, nicht wichtig.
Aber wir müssen wissen, dass die deutschen Piloten
nur mit LTF-Briefgeräten fliegen.
Und sonst weltweit
gilt der DN-Gütersiegel.
Was wird dort gemacht?
Es wird einerseits der Schirm
mit einer Schockbelastung
fest belastet.
Das ist auch nichts anderes, als der Schirm
an einem Fahrzeug mit einem langen Seil
angehängt wird.
Da ist eine Vollbruchstelle drinnen,
die dann reisst.
Danach schaut man den Schirm an,
ob er Schäden hat.
Wenn der Test erfolgreich war,
wird der Schirm nochmals eingespannt.
Das Auto fährt jetzt konjugierlich los,
beschleunigt immer mehr,
dass der Schirm, der hinten dranhängt,
auf 8G belastet wird.
8G ist das absolute Minimum.
Die heutigen Gleitschirmherstellungen
gehen eher drüber.
Wir sind eher bei 12 oder sogar 16G.
Wenn wir den Akrobatikschirm nehmen,
sind wir sicher eher bei 16G.
Auch dort wird nachher geprüft.
Es ist nichts kaputt gegangen.
Es sind alle Bauteile noch so,
wie sie sein sollten.
Es wird Gesamteindruck gemacht
und alles protokolliert.
Auch die Leinenfestigkeit wird geprüft.
Sind die auch so,
wie der Hersteller es angeht?
Eine Knickprüfung folgt.
Der Hersteller muss vorgängig machen
und beweisen, dass seine Leinen,
die er hier verbaut hat,
standhalten und der richtige Faden
verwendet wurde.
Das Ganze wird in einem Briefbericht
festgehalten.
Danach geht man weiter zum Flugtest.
Der Flugtest ist zuerst ganz allgemein.
Wie sind die Bremswege?
Bei einem Wettkampfschirm
sind die Bremswege eher gekürzt.
Da spricht man von 0 bis 30 cm.
Bei einem Schuhheilschirm
sind es eher von 0 bis 50 cm.
Das kann ein relativ langer Weg sein.
Das schaut man an.
Danach werden die Manöver geflogen.
Es sind 24 Manöver geflogen mit diesem Schirm.
Davon sind 90 Einzelpunkte,
die dann vergeben werden.
Das ist ein A-Schirm.
Wenn er 90 A hat, ist es ein A-Schirm.
Wenn er B hat, wird es eher ein B-Schirm.
Und so werden die ganzen Punkte vergeben.
Das Ganze ist aber ein bisschen schwierig
beim Gleitschirm,
weil es kein Messverfahren dafür gibt.
Das heisst, es ist schlussendlich
im Auge des Betrachters.
Es ist ein Experte, der unten ist.
Und der Testpilot in der Luft,
der beurteilt, dass das Manöver
ein A-Schirm oder ein B-Schirm ist.
Das Ganze ist so, dass
jedes Manöver fünf Mal geflogen werden kann.
Und wenn es einmal in die Kategorie
reingegangen ist, in die man will,
dann gilt es.
Das heisst, es kann vier Mal ein B-Schirm sein
und einmal ein A-Schirm.
Dann weiss man, bei welchem Manöver ein A-Schirm ist.
Das wird immer etwas kritisiert,
speziell von den Flugschulen.
Es wäre doch eher schöner,
wenn es eine Mehrheit gäbe.
Zum Beispiel drei Mal in das Manöver
in die Kategorie.
Dann wäre es etwas aussagekräftiger.
Aber auch so wichtig,
die Schirme, die wir haben,
ist schlussendlich unverzichtbar,
dass man eine Beratung holt bei den Flugschulen,
bei den Fluglehrern.
Denn die kennen die Schirme am besten
und wissen auch, wenn es einmal eine Macke hat.
Was aber sehr selten vorkommt.
Wir haben das Ganze heute sehr gut im Griff
und es sind sehr gute Schirme auf dem Markt.
Was wird überhaupt verbaut am Gleitschirm?
Grundsätzlich ist es
ein Polyamid, ein Nylon,
das durch ist.
Mit dieser Struktur drinnen,
die nennt man Ripstop.
Und zwar ist das nichts anderes
als eine Webtechnik,
die in Kette und Schuss erfolgt.
Und diese sollte eigentlich verhindern,
dass das Tuch, wenn es einmal ein Loch hat,
weiterreisst.
Das sind so kleine Barrieren im Tuch.
Und diese Barrieren sorgen dafür,
dass es nicht weiterreisst.
Aber man kann auch sehr dünne Stoffe verwenden,
die ein geringes Gewicht haben
und trotzdem sehr stabil sind.
Was nicht so gerne ist,
ist die Diagonalbelastung.
Dort ist eher mal ein Zug drinnen.
Allerdings verpackt man sie genau so,
damit die Belastung möglichst
aufs Tuch funktioniert.
Ein schweres Tuch,
hier reden wir von einem Gleitschirm,
handelsüblichen Gleitschirm,
der nicht speziell auf Licht gemacht ist,
sind wir ungefähr bei 49 Gramm pro Quadratmeter.
Als Vergleich ein A4-Brett,
das nicht darauf schreibt,
hat 80 Gramm pro Quadratmeter.
Es geht aber noch viel leichter,
nämlich mit 17 Gramm.
Dort sind wir dann im
Lichtbaubereich,
wo der Hersteller einen Schirmbau
für High-Comfly gemacht hat,
wo man Licht und wenig Packvolumen haben will.
Da sind wir noch bei 17 Gramm pro Quadratmeter.
Und diese Zahl, bin ich sicher,
wird in Zukunft noch weit oben runter gehen,
weil die Techniken werden fortgelaufen,
geforscht und gemacht.
Und natürlich ein Anliegen,
dass man einen Stoff hat, der gleich stabil ist
und noch leichter ist als das Ganze.
Was haben wir dann noch weiter für Materialien verbaut?
Wir haben den Schirm selbst,
den haben wir jetzt gelernt,
das ist ein Nylon letztendlich.
Ihr seht vielleicht auch in den Bergbahnen
die Werbung oben, dass man noch
Petflaschen verbaut,
in der Gleitschirmübertriebung gesagt.
Also schlussendlich einfach ein Kunststoffmix,
was im Gleitschirmbereich passiert.
Auch im Traggurtbereich
ist das Dynema Tochnora.
Von der Leine kommen wir dann gleich dazu,
speziell.
Wir haben den Notschirm selbst,
der aus einem Nylon ist.
Beim Notschirm selbst ist es so,
dass es eigentlich das gleiche Tuch ist,
einfach viel, viel feiner gewebbt.
Das ist es noch viel dünner,
weil natürlich Belastung beim Notschirm ein anderer ist.
Erstens, beim Notschirm darf es dehnen.
Es ist nicht so wichtig, dass er voll formstabil ist,
weil, gerade wenn es eine Schlagöffnung gibt,
ist es wichtig, dass das Ganze sich dehnt.
Das beginnt bei der Leine an, aber auch beim Tuch.
Darum macht es dort weniger,
wenn das Tuch nicht ganz so stabil ist.
Kommen wir auch nachher noch schnell dazu.
Was wir auch haben,
ist der Aluminium-Karabiner.
Wir haben einerseits Stahl und Aluminium auf dem Markt.
Hier scheiden sich die Geister.
Eine lange Diskussion,
wer denn wirklich besser ist.
Der Aluminium hat sicher ein wenig Nachteile
bei mechanischen Belastungen.
Wenn wir ihn auf einen Stein halten,
ist ein Aluminium sicher schneller eine Teledyn
als bei einem Stahlkarabiner.
Allerdings halten diese sehr, sehr lange und gut.
Und so im allgemeinen Gebrauch
sagen wir,
wir müssen jetzt etwa alle fünf Jahre wechseln.
Der Aluminium-Karabiner
bei Tests schneidet sogar ganz leicht besser ab.
Nämlich, wenn man den Test gemacht hat,
wo man ein paar Millimeter Spiel
auf und zu lassen hat machen.
Und das paar tausend Mal
hat schlussendlich die Festigkeit beim Aluminium besser gewesen.
Aber wir reden hier von Festigkeit,
die nicht unterschritten wird
im normalen Gebrauch.
Genau.
Der Bleitschirm hat viele Leinen.
Das ist das,
was auch entscheidend ist.
Weil mit dieser Leine kann man einerseits
viel machen, indem man Materialmix wählt.
Und wir versuchen natürlich
das Beste daraus zu holen,
dass jeder Schirm möglichst lang so fliegt,
wie er neu gebaut worden ist.
Weil dort bei Anspruchung gibt es da irgendeinen
Unterschied. Gewisse Leinen
schrumpfen ein wenig, gewisse Leinen dehnen
ein wenig und darum ist es wichtig,
dort einen sauberen Mix zu haben.
Wir fangen aber zuerst an beim Leinematerial,
beim Mantel.
Weil jede Leine, die ummantelt ist,
das zeige ich gleich so,
ist schlussendlich die Leine innen selber
und der Mantel rundherum.
Den Mantel macht man aus ganz einfachen Gründen,
nämlich vor allem die mechanische Belastung.
Sprich, wenn ich natürlich über einen Stein ziehe
oder die Leine untereinander reibe,
habe ich hier eine Schutzschicht drüber.
Das funktioniert sehr gut.
Und ich kann sie sauber farblich trennen.
Gerade bei Schulschirmen haben wir oftmals
in dem A-Bereich rote und dann andere Farben,
dass man von Anfang an den Anfänger sieht,
aha, diese Leine muss ich jetzt
für das in die Hand nehmen
und farblich sauber getrennt ist.
Das hat natürlich auch einen kleinen Nachteil,
nämlich dass die Leine viel dicker macht
und somit der Luftwiderstand
natürlich auch grösser ist.
Und gerade der Luftwiderstand ist etwas,
das man möglichst wenig halten will.
Darum machen wir schlussendlich auch Leinen,
die nicht ummantelt sind.
Die dann so aussehen,
die keinen Mantel haben.
Die haben natürlich auch den Vorteil,
dass wir sehr geringes Gewicht haben,
wenig Widerstand
und verschiedene Materialien werden hier aufgebaut.
Wir nehmen zuerst den Markennamen
der Leine Dynema.
Das ist die weisse Leine,
die wir hier sehen.
Sie ist aus enterem Polyethylen,
ein Kunststoff und die hat
eine gute Form.
Polyethylen ist aus enterem Kunststoff
und die hat den grossen Vorteil,
dass sie ein sehr gutes Gewicht-
und Festigkeitsverhältnis ist.
Sie ist leicht und hält doch sehr sehr viel.
Die UV-Beständigkeit ist hoch,
die Alterung ist auch sehr gut
und man kann sie sehr gut verarbeiten.
Sie hat eine super genaue Nadel,
die super spitz ist.
Mit dieser kann man relativ gut nähen
und sie lässt sich gut bearbeiten.
Kleiner Nachteil hat sie,
dass sie bei der Belastung auch dehnt.
Das sieht man beim Checken,
wenn man die Leine ausmessen muss.
Und vor allem bei der Nichtbelastung
schrumpft sie auch ein wenig.
Das heisst, wenn natürlich
der Gleitschirm fliegt,
hat er ungefähr
80% der ganzen Belastung
auf A- und B-Ebene.
Und hinten auf C- oder D-Ebene
sind die restlichen 20%.
Das heisst natürlich,
wenn man diese Leine verbaut
im C- und D-Bereich,
wo sie kaum belastet wird,
da sind wir dann vielleicht
noch bei 300-500g pro Leine,
dann haben wir dort eher mal
einen Schrumpf drin.
Die andere, die auf dem Markt ist,
ist die Aramid-Leine Technora Kevlar.
Der Markenname hat eine geringe Dehne,
ist sehr länger stabil
und ein hoher Schmelzpunkt.
Sie hat eine etwas brünliche Farbe.
Und dort ist ganz klar der grosse
Nachteil, dass sie etwas knickerpfindlich ist.
Und gerade wenn sie
knickerpfindlich ist,
muss man gut darauf schauen,
wo man sie verbaut.
Weil, wenn natürlich am Schirm
ein Teil ist, wo man sagt,
es wird jetzt eher stark belastet,
dann ist es wichtig,
dass sie dort unempfindlich ist
gegenüber diesem Knicken
oder eben auch vor allem
einer geringen Stabilität.
Darum ist es eigentlich immer ein Mix
zwischen der Aramid-Leine
und der Dyneema-Leine,
dass man sagt, man tut im oberen Bereich
vielleicht eher in die Dyneema hinein
und im unteren eher in die Aramid-Leine hinein.
Einfach, um den Mix möglichst so zu haben,
dass man den schlussendlich im Griff hat.
Die UV-Belastung
ist ein kleiner Nachteil.
Darum vermantelt man sie oftmals.
Oder wenn man sie nicht vermantelt,
gibt es eine solche Beschichtung,
wo man sie mittlerweile auch ein wenig einfärben kann.
So findet die farbliche Trennung statt.
Das ist eigentlich die Kunst,
dass man die Unmantel-Leine so beschichten kann,
dass trotzdem die UV-Belastung
sehr gut ist und funktioniert.